[Applause]
[Music]
you got your license on you
one second okay
mr bell you're in your registration has
been suspended since uh
uh february for an insurance lapse
did you have some sort of labs or do you
switch insurance or anything
okay yeah your reg is suspended right
now
it's uh it's not really a big deal uh
we're just gonna get we're gonna have
you step out and we'll work with you and
go from there okay
yeah just coming down here chill
okay all right no big deal
you got shot two weeks ago
oh in 2012 oh jesus okay um
i'll just have you step out slowly then
i guess are you able
yeah it's uh
sorry
all right
[Applause]
both side passenger air driver
radio passenger and driver both firing
shots
and the car is approaching us he is
firing head on
he is firing at any officer coming close
shooting shooting
driver is still shooting
the shoot right now the student right
now
still shooting protein sycamores
we're losing something here
tell me
right
driver drive down the street driver
what's gonna happen here
is
watch out guys you will shoot
[Applause]
jefferson passing george
jefferson
tell that mark to be careful to shoot at
him unmarked be careful
passing the 33 on-ramp still on
jefferson northbound
northbound
33.
clear
[Applause]
hello
oh shit
oh shit everett 441 radio we're heading
to ucmc my partner's hit
okay
now we're heading there
okay
go let's get covered
now
[Applause]
get back in the car get down get out of
the
way
he's coming this way
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
she's hard
where are they going away
anything
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
we're approaching film we're approaching
fillmore speed is 20.
officers be careful
heads up on fillmore heads up on
fillmore he's approaching now
[Applause]
south korea
you